non vous êtes accompagné par le dj case
rocher
je suis pas là j'suis pas long j'y vais
m'asseoir sur la lune parce que y'a rien
à faire de bruit je suis pas là j'suis
paleron je suis j'ai donné l'innocence
mais j'ai gardé les étoiles dans les
yeux cheville j'irai m'asseoir sur la
lune parce que y'a rien à faire de mieux
si je suis pas là j'suis pas l'on suit
je donnais l'innocence mais j'ai gardé
les étoiles dans les yeux chimie
adolescents si t'as pas de quartier tu
deviens tu deviens fou car la première
question des autres et tu viens tu viens
d'où j'ai roulé ma bosse dans les creux
des villes sans voir les projectiles
carla une m'a donné la main et protéger
des mauvais coups j'ai des textes l'un
comme d'autres et c'est le flou me
percent les mots me sers j'ai pris des
miettes des grains des reds ont fait du
bruit du sont durs dans ma cervelle
selectric l'ambiance n'a jamais tamise
des textes écrits il y a dix piges la
feuille n'a pas cicatrisé d'une planète
dans la tête je vis ici en dilettante et
je repars en retard les gens peuvent
voir qu'il peut beaucoup pleuvoir dans
nos gares mais que fait la police quand
la terre fait tourner la lune si la
terre s'est marié au vice c'est parce
que le vi fait la une des meilleures
choses sont dans les rêves je les
emporte quand je divague
je détiens sur ce père si la douane
laisse passer mon récital garder ses
rêves
grandir avant la chute parce que j'ai
accepté grand court mais pas verrouillée
on a tous qui rêvasse l'art sur la lune
parce que y'a viennent à faire de mieux
j'suis pas là je suis pas loin je suis
j'ai donné l'innocence mais j'ai gardé
des étoiles dans les yeux de chimène
asseoir sur la lune parce que y'a rien à
faire de mieux
j'suis pas là j'suis pas le mans je suis
je donnais l'innocence mais j'ai gardé
les étoiles dans les yeux cheville et
ses ressorts l'allument appel je suis en
coloc avec pierrot on et fly sous
pesanteur la voie lactée sert de déco le
monde autour de thé se fasse ça donne le
vertige mais c'est rien on a un petit
peu plus l'espace en appartement
d'intérieur je verrai plus le goal de
rapaces menno meyjes taquine par contre
dit om si kippel ma place que je fais
payer partout la lune appelle les
esprits solitaire pas les grandes
gueules elle parle à beaucoup parce que
je suis pas le seul à être seul seul
devant son art il vend sa vraie nature
en vrai on tremble même les plus
courageux s'associent disent on est
ensemble à l'école j'avais l'imagination
silice civis jeu transformé mon heure de
15 ans lors d'une rixe
le glissement au plus qu'à changer le
monde paban demandé ma carte mon un
désir yakro de réponse que je veux pas
voir mais qui s'entassent dans ma raison
car dès les rêves et les brandir avant
la chute
parce que j'ai accepté de grandir mais
pas de rouille et on a tous tiré masse
noire sur la lune parce que y'a rien à
faire de mieux
si je suis pas là j'suis pas lourd je
suis
regarder les étoiles dans les yeux
juillet j'irai m'asseoir sur la lune
parce que y'a rien à faire de mieux
si je suis pas là je suis pas loin je
suis généreux d'innocence mais j'ai
gardé des étoiles dans les yeux shui
merci respect on vous retrouve